Welcome to the lecture on database implementation.
So in the last week we have looked at B-trees.
We saw all kinds of problems that we had, for example, if we have variable length keys.
So if we do this naively, bad things can happen.
So then we talked about, okay, what can we do?
How should we choose separators?
And so to improve the fan out so that we get a high fan out, because high fan out means low depth.
So this is highly desirable.
So now to finally conclude this B-tree chapter, we look at one more trick or two small tricks that
we can do to improve B-trees, again to improve the fanout. And these are so-called prefix B-plus
trees. Note that there are two different techniques that people historically call prefix B-plus trees.
So it's not exactly the same. Now they're similar ideas, but the technology are different.
So the first thing, this is a pretty easy trick basically, is what you see on this page here.
You can say, you know, in a prefix B plus 3, it's not necessary that the separator does occur in the
data. It can occur in the data, but it doesn't have to. So we can choose anything as separator,
as long as it separates my left and my right side. So here we see, if one node here contains
And A, A, A, B, B, B, so two pretty long strings.
Then another bucket here.
So now what should I choose as separator?
All strings are long, but we can see if you look at them, now between B and E, there are
other letters, so I could for example choose C here as separate.
Or of course, just as well, I could have chosen D, it doesn't matter.
It matters a bit considering future inserts.
But concerning the pure lookup, both C and D would have been fine.
So we could have chosen anything.
And because we can choose anything as long as we can separate left and right, what we
will do is we will choose the smallest possible separator such that left and right is separated.
Okay, this is a pretty small idea.
A beautiful property of this approach is that we don't have to change anything.
Now, of course, the moment it shoots the separator, I have to run a bit of logic,
but otherwise lookup works the same, so no change at all is necessary.
Only the lookup, the choice of separators to be modified.
Now, looks good.
Now in practice, there are two problems, or perhaps one problem,
do this? So I said, we look at B and we look here, we look at this string, if we look at that string,
then we say, okay, C is between this. Yeah, but how do I do this for arbitrary data types?
So what, I mean, basically I said in the last lecture that we usually assume that B2 stores
blobs, so we don't understand the content and therefore it's pretty hard to choose this. If
we don't understand the data type, I cannot choose this between. If I know that these two are strings,
number between them.
And strictly speaking, even if I know that this is strings, choosing a separator is not
that easy.
Now, we could say here BBBEE, clear how to do this, just use a short string between them.
But what happens if we start having, for example, locale information, like this German umlauts,
For example, if you have something like this, so this here is an umlaut, how do I choose
a separator for this?
So this is potentially sorted like this.
And how do I choose a separator that separates this?
Suddenly this becomes complicated.
So I wouldn't need rules per language perhaps, or in general cases, it's not even possible.
Because if you think about the implementation, I mean it should be,
or I don't mean this is implementation lecture, I can talk about this a bit.
So if you want to store locale independent, sorry, not locale independent, locale dependent
ordering, like if you want to sort strings language dependent, yes, because you will
German you might sort them differently, or I mean English and German are not too different, they're
pretty similar, but the other languages that sort really funny, like if you remember correctly,
if in Danish, if you have a string within double A, this is suddenly treated especially, this is
sorted differently from everything else. So these are these kinds of rules, if you want to do this
properly for each language.
Now there is a mechanism here that is a so-called Unicode Collate algorithm, that basically
takes your string here and then maps your string into a sequence of weights, so your
Unicode weights.
And we can then compare this weight, so this works.
Problem is, this mapping is not bijective, so therefore we cannot reverse it.
It's pretty difficult to find a string that is between these two arbitrary strings.
So if I give you two arbitrary strings and say give me a string that is in between them,
if it's just an SQ string that is reasonably easy, but if this is a unicode string, it's
not easy at all.
And it depends on the language that you have, but even independent of this problem is pretty
difficult.
Okay, so these kind of perfect split class trees are nice, but not as universal as you
might think.
And now there's a second kind of approach of PRVs plus trees.
And this now really assumes nearly nothing about this.
This works also for blobs, so we don't pretend to understore the content.
And here's observation is, if you have, I mean, whatever Btree does it,
it sorts its input lexicographically by definition, because all my input is
in increasing order, so all my input is sorted.
Now, if you think about a telephone book, for example, which is like a Btree in
flat.
So if you think this, you notice that neighboring entries tend to be very similar.
Because in a telephone book everything is sorted by last name and first name.
Therefore neighboring entries tend to have the same last name or if it's not the same
then at least very similar.
And this is also a trick that we can use.
So here we have an example where we assume we store two URLs on my page.
So I might have an URL for Google and for Sigmod, for example.
And we realized this, the full URL, we would have two URLs, both of them start with HTTP.
.
And then google.com and then the same here, same Sigmod.org.
Okay.
No, sorry.
Org.
So this we store two times, in fact not only two times, but a hundred times.
But so neighboring entries here, all of them on a page, on a single page, all of them might
begin with this sequence.
And therefore instead of storing this sequence every time, what we can do is we factor out
the prefix that is the same for all keys on my current page.
So this here is the prefix for the page.
And we store the prefix only once and we implicitly know that all other entries on the page must
be prepended with this prefix.
And this saves a lot of space of course if the neighboring entries are similar.
Here, so in my example here, we save, I don't know, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven,
11 bytes per entry. So we have many of them, then we can save quite a bit and have a much higher fanout.
Good thing is, so the change into the lookup logic is minor. So if I go to a page, the only
thing I have to do, I have to compare my search key with the prefix, because I know that all
entries on my page will have the same prefix.
Now so if I'm larger than this, I can immediately go to the next entry.
If I have the same prefix as the prefix on the page, then I strip this from my search
key and then just search for the rest.
Now so if you know, if somebody would have to technically search for
slash slash dub dub dub dot vldb dot org or something like this.
So while searching, I would realize, oh this is my common prefix.
And then I would just search for vldb.org on the page, because I know that all entries
on the page have the same prefix.
Okay, so it's a pretty small change.
That's good.
Now for lookup it's fine.
If you want to scan, so if you want to produce outputs to the user, this is a bit more complicated
because if you want to report it to the user, then we must reconstruct this.
So then we must concatenate this here and this here, and we must concatenate this and
this, because this is a foot string.
between sequences of two parts, I must reconstruct this.
And therefore, if I want to avoid this cost of reconstruction,
I might only do this prefix compression
in the inner nodes, because in the nodes
there's no disadvantage.
And as inner nodes, I always just go down,
I do a search, so inner nodes, I can always do this.
On the leaf pages where I can at least potentially
do a range query, so I want to output everything
in a certain range, there I might care
about this reconstruction cost and then it don't stall this. On the other hand,
I mean it's true that some people do index only queries, which means queries that just reads
index and then this prefix factoring hurts you, but I think in most cases even on the leaf pages
this is a win. So prefix b plus 3 is a pretty good idea. So usually you will want to do this.
Again you save a lot of space and by saving a lot of space you get a higher fan out.
So this is quite good, in particular if you have long strings in your index.
Okay and so as I think I already said this already, so the electrographic short order
makes perfect comparison attractive, and we have to say that they tend to have the same
key for neighboring entries.
And of course, two things, so this not only works for strings, this is an example, but
So if we indexed lines something like A and B, neighboring entries tend to have the same values
for A. So factoring out this A is important, it's quite useful. In particular, I think if you think
about partition B trees, where we talked about that we prepend an artificial value to everywhere,
and a partition B tree basically requires you to implement a prefix B plus tree.
Because if you do this prefix compression here on a partition B tree, the partition costs you
nothing because you don't really store the partition.
The partition is stored only once per page and you have a thousand entries on the page.
So this space consumption doesn't really matter.
And we stored only once and then we can factor it out.
So this is, this partition B-trays are very natural combination with previous B-plus trees.
Now for strings everything works as it is.
For numerical values, you might wish to store your values in big engine order, not in little
engine order.
So I hope it's clear why, because if you think, let's say I want to store the value, I must
use small numbers so everything works out.
So let's say I want to store the value 258, so this is my value 258.
Now if I store this in big engine order, which means most significant byte first, so then
this binary representation here is 1, 2.
Big Endian because this is of course 1 times 256 plus 2.
So therefore Big Endian encoding is 1, 2 and if I would have the value 259, then as next
value then of course the binary represents the pick engine encoding would be 1,3.
And we see what happens, first byte is the same, second byte is increasing, therefore
we can factor out the common prefix. If I instead would store this as little engine, which means
I store a least significant byte first, then this here would be encoded as 2,1 and
3,1. This is of course not good for prefix compression because now neighboring entries
So if you want to store numerical values, you want to store them in big engine order,
not in little engine order.
Note that your machine that you're using most likely is little engine machine, because little
engine has one.
So historically there have been big engine and little engine machines, but Intel machines
are little engine and most of you are probably using Intel machines or AMD machines, but
they are the same, so it doesn't have to be Intel, but you know, x86 machines.
And these are little engine and the little engines have won the fight.
Both encodings have pros and cons, so it doesn't really matter what you do.
So I mean the advantage of little engine by the way is you can store the values of this
different bit width on the same address without changing the pointer.
So like if I want to load 16 byte values and then store it a 32 byte value, I can just
do it in the same address.
And with big engine I have to update my pointer.
But this is really not a big deal, it's not so frequent yet you do this.
And in principle it wouldn't matter what you would do, but nevertheless the little engine
machines have one.
So most people use nowadays little Indian machines.
And for this particular use case here, you want to store your values big Indian,
even if that is not your native encoding.
By the way, if you want to do this in code swapping, swapping between these two big Indian and little Indian,
just cost you one assembly instruction.
It's very cheap.
Here's this bswap instruction so that you can use, and then this converts little to a big Indian and the other way around.
to care about PDP encoding, then everything's fine. So big Indian and little Indian, these are all
same encodings. Okay, so much for B-trees. We talked about already more than one lecture,
one and a half lecture, so about B-trees. And of course, B-trees are the most important data
structure for external memory. So B-trees are the universal data structure for external memory.
They work well for all kinds of use cases. They are pretty useful. But nevertheless,
Yes, even though they are the most important ones, they are not the only ones.
There are also other alternatives that we can use.
And one important family of approaches are hash-based approaches.
I hope you all know this from regular programming.
If you have installed and want to store something in memory, and you just want to retrieve an
element and store an element and retrieve it, then you can use the hash table.
And the big advantage of a hash table, of course, is that we can
access an element in constant time, while with the search tree we have logarithmic time.
Of course, this is more or less a promise, I will come back to this in a moment.
Just to repeat this, so if I want to store 1 million entries,
So then if I do this in a repository, then until I find my one, so if I do search something
here, look up, look up.
If I would do this in a repository, then I know I have to look at between 20 to 40 elements
that I must consider.
and because of course there's my root fork down here somewhere to my elements and i usually have
to i have to go and i did my depth here in oh of dangerous
it's difficult to use in a very really precise way okay we know that's it so i shouldn't say
elements, I say depth. So the depth of my write black tree is between 20 and 40 elements.
So how deep it is depends on your insert order, your values and so on, it's not so easy to say.
But this depth of my write black tree is between 20 and 40. Therefore if I have to go to something,
on average I have to go to something like 30 elements or so. So in this ballpark, 30 elements.
I say on average because it could be that of course,
that I search for some elements that's currently the root.
It could be that one element I'm done.
But the vast majority of the elements, of course,
is further down the tree.
And therefore on average, I'd access something like 30,
let's just say, approximately 30 elements accessed,
elements accessed per lookup.
So, and this of course, not very cheap.
If I do this in a red black tree, we already learned red black tree is bad.
Now, so if I do this instead in a B tree, that's probably better.
So let's say I have a fan out of, I can fit the 1000 elements on a tree.
So then my depth here will be between two and three.
Again, depends a bit on how my insert works.
So between, so this is the depth.
And now how many elements will I access?
Yeah.
So this is a good question, interestingly similar, but with better locality.
So, of the roughing side, 30 elements per lookup.
Now you could go around, why 30?
Didn't I say 2 to 3?
Yeah, this is true.
And and by the way, I mean I didn't talk about the constants here. So this 30 will be much cheaper than this 30
No, just just saying but nevertheless and the absolute number of elements that you consider
B trees and the right leg trees do more or less the same
So now perhaps it's a bit better. Perhaps it's not 30. Perhaps it's probably it's more like 20-ish
Oh, yeah
It cannot be 30, 30 is too high.
Let's say 21.
21 is probably a reasonable number.
Okay, now how do I come up with 21?
Nevertheless, 21 would have been even 30.
So 30 would have been much cheaper in the B-tree than in the red black tree.
Now how can I come up with this number?
Remember a B-tree looks like this.
So this is my root.
And now assuming I have depth 2, and then this means of course that my root is 0.
and my leaf page are all full.
So then I have 1000 elements here and 1000 elements here.
So now when I traverse down,
I do a binary search on each level,
which means I do a binary search on 1000 elements.
And this cost me 10, look at 10 elements
because we know that, yeah.
So log two to 1k is 10.
And I should say, of course, approximately
okay if it's 20,024. So this is 10 and therefore I look at 10 elements on the root, I look at 10 elements
at the leaf and then therefore I come to 20. Now why it's at 21, because if you're unlucky with
insertion order you need one level more but your b tree is your root will in this case only contain
two pointers. So therefore something like 21. So you look outside quite a few elements
But of course you have better locality than in a red-black tree, so you will be faster
in practice.
But nevertheless, you will look at a quite similar number of elements, even though your
depth is much better.
Much, much better.
Okay, so now the promise of a hash table is as follows.
Hash table, I hope you all work how hash table works.
Hash table says, I look at one element, well let's say two elements, one to two elements.
And then I'm done.
Okay, this of course, yeah, this is much, much, much, much less than the others.
And therefore hash tables are, hash table, therefore hash tables are much faster than
either B-trees or reflect trees.
Hash tables are in a way the best.
I say in a way, because I mean, there's a lot of fine print here.
First, of course, obvious problems.
In a B-tree you can do a range query.
give me everything between 20 and 30 you cannot do this in the hash table.
You can only search for one precise value and that's it.
And that's why this of course is a great limitation.
Second limitation is here, I mean I gave you absolute numbers and what we expect and so,
but we know in absolute terms, we know that in the lookup cost for a Btree is
O of log n where I have n entries.
And I know this.
Okay, with a hash table, now what is the lookup cost here?
So we say expected is constant excess.
Now we have one or two elements and that's it.
Unfortunately, worst case, or when.
In the worst case, the hash table is much worse than ease of the trees.
Hash tables can have, in theory, terrible performance.
Now in practice it doesn't really happen usually.
But this is of course a dark art.
It means strictly speaking it is not on the slide, but nevertheless I want to spend a
few minutes on this, because this is a pretty important thing in my opinion.
Hash tables are super useful, have great performance and so on.
And they are surprisingly nasty to do right.
So that it really works reliably in all cases.
Or if I can, therefore this is the reason why I brought this here.
We promise constant time access.
But here you also see if everything works out fine.
So if everything does not work out fine, then bad things happen.
So, hash tables are good usually, but usually it's not always.
Or to quote Donald Knuth, he said, hash tables are great for people who have a lot of faith
in statistics.
And this is absolutely true.
So if you look at the statistics, it says on the expectance value, hash tables have
far superior performance than everything else.
Worst case, not so good.
The worst case is really, really bad in a hash table, but of course it's extremely unlikely
that this worst case ever happens.
And now we'll see how to make this worst case unlikely.
So first let's briefly repeat how to implement a hash table.
Now of course there are two schools of implementing a hash table, 200 probably, but let's say
two important schools of implementing a hash table.
One is chaining and one is open addressing.
So let's start perhaps with a simple chaining hash table, just to make this example here
clear.
So this is hash table.
By the way, I hope that everybody of you could implement this hash table himself at home,
without my help.
Because I'm pretty sure that you did this in your introduction to algorithmic data structures.
So therefore I hope you all know this.
I'm pretty sure, I hope this, I'm pretty sure that's not true.
So at least some of you might have got the idea of how a hash table works, but from experience
I know that's a great difference between understanding the idea and really grasping the details.
And therefore I strongly recommend you to implement a hash table.
Actually I think you will do this exercise.
And so implement a hash table because after you have implemented it, you realize much
better how everything works.
Because if you, I mean, I can draw a picture here, and this looks super convincing to you,
but the picture is not code, because the picture is very generous in how everything works.
So I strongly recommend you to implement a hash table and implement a good hash table.
So then you get a much, much nicer intuition of how everything works.
Okay, but let's now start.
Let's say this is my hash table.
So let me say my hash table has the size, here is position zero and up to, yeah, how
large do we make it?
A good question.
Let's say we give it a size here, this is n minus one, so we size n.
Okay.
So I have a lot of entries here.
Now if I want to insert an element here, so let us say, yes, insert.
So this is a hash table here, and my hash table is perhaps make it even more concrete.
I say I have an entry struct entry.
And my entry here contains a key for simplicity, I will just use an integer because it could
be anything here.
Let's use an integer and then entry star next.
So as I said, we implemented chaining hash table.
my entry here and my hash table now is entry star hash table of size n okay so my hash
table basically is a big array of pointers initially all everything is zero here and
And now let's look up here, so when we say lookup key, so how do we do this?
we say the slot where my key belongs, slot is equal to hash of keys, so my hash function
here maps my key to the integer domain basically.
So I will talk more about the hash function in a moment, but basically my hash function
does, it takes a key, in this case integer of course, but could be a string, could be
anything.
So I take my search value and transform it into an integer.
Here, so basically a hash function here, let's put it here, this maps my key to an int.
And so this is what a hash function does.
And so, and then we say, for example, the classical implementation says, hash mod n.
So we just take my hash value and then modulo n.
And then we say, okay, for i equals hash table slot, so as long as my i is not null, then
I said if i k key equals key, I'll write backwards, sorry, it's equals key, then we say return found.
So this is a very simple thing here, then return not found, return.
I'm sorry, so we say return
Not found.
So this is the most primitive implementation you can think of.
And then of course here we say v i equals i.next.
Now in reality you might wish to store not only a key but also a payload, like something
like a dictionary.
So once you associate something with the key, then you put in here a payload.
And then of course we say in this case payload if you want.
and then of course here we would say return payload instead of return phone yeah so this is
what we would do if we have so if we have a more complex htab. Nevertheless this is a very very
simple htchaining htab. And a good thing is this is only a little code. A bad thing is this is even
though it looks so so simple it's surprisingly difficult to implement at least difficult in a
way that it works well.
Even though this is a very simple conceptually simple thing.
By the way, as I said, please implement it at some point.
Because if I draw you a picture here and say, okay, this is my entry that contains a 4, then
because I have a hash collision, perhaps I also get a 4 here in the 20.
And then here I store the 5.
So this is how a hash tab looks in practice.
So we have elements and then we take the key element.
find a slot and then we have a chain of entries,
therefore the name chaining, that then contains the element.
And if I show you this picture,
everybody says, oh, I know if you search for 20,
I just go there.
Because you as a human, of course,
sees the whole hash table.
But the computer doesn't see the whole hash table,
it has to look at one element after the other.
Yeah, so this is therefore more subtle than you might think.
Okay, now what is problematic about this current code?
There are three things that are bad.
Now where should I start?
Perhaps I start with this.
So let's look at this point.
Here we say, in this point we say,
I take my hash value, which is an arbitrary integer,
and then I take modulo, my hash table size,
and this gives me the slot where I have to go to.
Now we don't like modulo.
So perhaps even stepping one step back
before we come to the model of problem.
The next question of course is how large should N be?
So how large should I make my hash table?
And in practice what you want is
that your hash table is as large
as your number of elements that you have,
plus a bit more.
And now how much is a bit more,
is not so easy to say,
but let's just say you want,
I mean, if you don't want to make it much larger
than the number of elements that you have,
because otherwise you raise a lot of space.
nothing in there, so you don't want this.
So you want your f-tables to be similar in size to the number of elements.
In reality, you want to make it a bit larger because the fuller your hash table is, the
more likely it is that two elements end up in the same bucket here.
And therefore you have a longer chain and then your performance degrades.
I said, initially we say we expect constant time, which means we expect to look at only
one element here or on average perhaps at 1.6 elements or so.
the average length of a chain in a chain in a hash table,
the one dot something elements, one or two,
this is what we expect.
But if you make my hash table very full,
so it's not large enough for some of the elements,
then my chains will get longer,
then the performance will be worse.
Because this fall loop here will get slower,
the longer my, so the longer my chain is,
the slower my fall loop is.
Therefore you want to have to a hash table reasonably large.
So, and for example, rule of thumb is you want a hash table is at most, at most, let's say
70% full.
For example, and if it's more than, so you choose it, so that's almost 20% or perhaps
you go a bit higher to 75% or so, but something like this.
And as a hash table size that you choose, N here probably should be a prime number.
teach in introductory courses should be prime.
So this is what we teach.
Now the interesting question is, why should n be a prime number?
And by the way, it's true.
In first approximation, choosing n as a prime number is a good idea.
So I don't want to say this is wrong.
So choosing n as a prime is a good idea, but interesting question is why?
Because, I mean, if you think just about what Modulo does,
Modulo does basically a wraparound.
And so if, let's say, if we know five is a prime number.
So if I take my values,
one, two, three, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
and I do this Modulo five,
then of course I get nicely spread around.
So a code here, this maps to zero, one, two, three,
four, zero, one, two,
would continue 3, 4, so 8, 9.
So if you take my prime number, then everything is spread out evenly and we want this of course
because we want that all buckets are filled uniformly.
And therefore prime number works.
But if I would choose non-prime number, like for example 4, which is definitely not a prime
number, so this is not prime, but if I take my input here, then what would happen is I
Let's take 0, 1, 2, 3, 0, 1, 2, 3, 0, 1, and so on.
It wraps around just as nice.
So therefore, why should I use a prime number?
Because if you just look at the wrapping behavior, prime number, no prime number, it doesn't matter at all.
The reason why you in reality want to use a prime number is as follows.
here your hash function, we didn't say anything about the hash function yet.
Yeah, my hash function must map my key to an integer domain,
but we did not explain yet how to do this.
And in reality, this is a black art. I will come back to this in a moment, but this is a black art.
So this is pretty difficult to do in a reasonable way.
And assume that your hash function is not perfect, which means
for example, your hash function tends to have a linear factor in it.
Like you could say, the hash values that you construct
are more likely to be multiple of two, for example.
So if there's some linear factor in your hash function,
and trust me, most simple hash functions
tend to have a linear factor.
And so linear factors are frequent,
it's not an exception, it's frequent.
So if your hash function has a linear factor
the size of hash table to the thing that you do a model of
Has this linear factor as they can be divided by this in a factor then terrible things happen
Yeah, assume for example that your hash function here tends to be produce values that are
even yes, they said a multiple of two and
Then if you end then choose four as hash table, then you can only construct the elements
zero and two
This element 1 and 3 can never happen because if my hash function is even, then I can never
trigger the hit points 1 and 3.
And this is clearly bad.
That is because then this leads to a very uneven distribution in your hash table and
then performance is terrible.
Now if your hash table is a prime number, then this only happens if the linear factor
happens to be your prime number.
So if your linear factor is not the prime number,
then this does not happen because by definition,
a prime number can only be divided by itself.
So therefore prime numbers are safer to choose
than non-prime numbers.
Okay, so this is the reason why we teach our,
in our introductory class,
we teach that you choose a prime number.
Nevertheless, even if you did choose a prime number,
we had to clear this because I need space,
but we had to hit this code here.
They will set slot is hash of X mod N.
And so assume N is prime,
so then some problems are solved.
But what is still super, super unpleasant here
is modulo is an extremely expensive operation.
Now this cost you, performing a modulo cost you
something like approximately 100 cycles.
Depends on your processor and so on,
not easy to say, but in the power pack of a hundred cycles,
and a hundred cycle is an insane high amount of time.
So doing something in model law is super, super expensive.
So you basically, you don't want to do this.
Don't, if you can avoid this,
don't implement a model of parameter by stable.
This is too expensive.
I mean, at least,
I mean, if you are on disk doesn't matter that much,
but in memory, these 100 cycles here
will really hurt your performance.
Okay, but what should you do instead?
Basically, there are three options,
all of them involved to different degrees.
Okay, now, first trick, option A.
Make a model N cheap.
And how do we do this?
Yeah, you know, what you mean, if you ever looked,
and unfortunately this is a recording now,
and I cannot do this, shows this to you live.
So what I would now show you live,
if you ever go to this great website here,
what's your url if you go to this greatest website oops sorry i messed up my presentation here
godbolch.org
and there what you can do there is you enter some code and then it shows you the generated
assembler code then if you do something like this you say um in on let's say for for didactic
use an int because the code is simpler if you don't say it's unsigned integer unsigned
x then we say return x mod 7.
So if you do this, then what will happen is, at least I hope I will check this myself in a moment,
but I'm pretty sure this happens. I just didn't check the similar code before,
but I'm pretty sure that's fine.
So I have to charge this one second.
So then what happens is if you look at the generated
assembler code,
or it's still not as easy as I would have hoped it to be.
Is the integer case in this case easier?
Let me check.
No, not easier, easier.
It's plain division.
Let's, let's, slightly, but it's okay.
It just, you can use the code that I showed here.
So but nevertheless, if you, if you run this, if you do this in, in Godbolt and you look
at the general code, you would see that your general code does not contain a division.
Yeah.
because the compiler knows that the division is terribly expensive and modulo is basically
is a division. So it doesn't have a division because it's super, super expensive. Instead,
what it will do, it will pre-compute some magic numbers. And then these, by the way,
I really call this, you can google for this. We say search for magic numbers division.
And then instead of doing a division, you do a sequence of multiplication and shift.
So you do multiply and shift and then you get the result of the division without doing the
division by pre-computing these magic numbers here.
Of course, pre-computing the magic numbers cost you something, it's not totally for free.
On the other hand, you can, as this is what I did at some point, you can have, for example,
a pre-computed list of all prime numbers between,
so between zero and two to the power of 64.
So if you pre-compute all prime numbers
between in this range and do this such
that they are 10% apart,
so not really all prime numbers,
because there's of course there are many,
but all prime numbers that are at least 10% apart
in this range, and then you can pre-compute
this magic numbers and then you can make this,
you can make this model look cheap.
Nevertheless, this is a pretty involved step here.
So this here is computing magic number is,
hard to do this but nevertheless it's difficult so you probably don't want
either you want to take the pre-computer list from somewhere or perhaps look up
the code for them probably you don't want to look at the code let's say this
is impossible but involved yeah so making model cheap not easy okay option
b. Don't use, or let's say, perhaps do use, make sure that, but don't use a prime number,
but make sure that n is a power of 2. Because if you do this, yes, so if n is a power of
Then, modulo computations are super cheap.
Because modulo, because if it is the power of 2, then we know that x mod n is the same
as x binary and n minus 1.
So, in this computation, of course, takes you two cycles or so, super cheap, while the
other one takes you 100 cycles.
So, modulo of a power of two is super, super cheap.
So great performance.
So plusing performance.
Negative, I mean I'm no longer very flexible
how my hash table looks like,
because the only thing I can do is
I can increase my hash table by a factor two.
Because if I always have to choose a power of two,
I don't have many choices with hash table sizes.
hash table size limited.
Hash table,
table,
table size is limited.
Okay, I must always choose the power of two.
So this means I probably waste quite a bit of space
because I cannot make a hash table size
is just slightly larger than my number of elements.
I make it quite a bit larger.
Yeah, and a second disadvantage here is,
This requires a good hash function.
That's a good hash function.
But this is probably true for others, or these others don't know this.
So option A is more forgiving.
So if you have a terrible hash function, A will be slightly better.
B will be, requires a good hash function.
So B will be terrible if your hash function is poor, a good hash function.
And then we come back to this in a moment, what this means.
Okay.
But we said, for example, if your input is, has a linear factor and your linear factor
happens to be two or contain two, yeah.
Then of course, choosing a power of two hash tables is not good because then a very bad
thing happens.
Yeah.
So you will only fill a very small part of hash table.
So therefore this, having good hash table, hash function is crucial for the option B.
Option C by the way, this is another neat trick that we can do.
We say the following, we do my say slot is equals to
So hash x times n, right shift, if we use 32 bit numbers, 32.
And this, but this multiplication here must be a 64 bit multiplication, 64 bit multiplication.
So, at first glance, you might be surprised that this works at all.
So basically what we do is we take my hash value and then I take my hash table size,
I multiply this, I shift this to the right by stage 2 and that's it.
And perhaps some of the surprising reasons indeed works.
So now why does this work?
here because I mean your hash function here is, so this value here is in between in the
range 0 to 2 to the power of 32 minus 1, yeah, or could I decide this is the range, then
I multiply this with hash double size.
So this means my result here is that also after this result I get a value between 0
0 and 2 to the power of 32, perhaps I should do this not with minus 1, but I should just
say without minus 1, but say an exclusive bound.
So and then the result here is in between 0 and 2 to the power of 32 times n exclusive.
And therefore if after the shift here, then the result of course is in the range 0 and
n exclusive.
now so this
Beautiful thing is we just need one multiplication and
and
Shift we do not we are not limited in hash table size. We cannot choose out the arbitrary has table sizes
Yes, if you do you want like auto prime number for anything we want and
So good thing here is cheap
Also good, arbitrary sizes.
Arbitrary sizes.
Bad thing.
This only works, well I mean this always works, but this only works reasonably well if your
hash function is very good.
and it requires a very good hash function.
Very good hash function.
Here again, I will come back to this in a moment
when we talk about hash functions.
But basically, this reasoning here assumes
that your hash function is distributed uniformly
across the whole domain.
Here's the whole integer domain
and must be spread out
and there must be no correlation
between input and hash function at all.
with a very strong requirement,
but basically you, this must be very neatly distributed.
Because I mean, I will talk about hash functions
in the moment, if you choose a bad hash function here,
what will happen is that you will always end up
in the same slot.
Now, so performance will be terrible
if you choose a bad hash function.
So this option C is the most flexible
and also pretty cheap,
but this requires a very, very, very good hash function.
Okay, so this is, and this brings me to the last problem
the last of it, actually there's one more, but okay.
But let's say perhaps the most critical hash
problem of hash tables,
how do we implement this hash function here?
We said, I need a hash function X
that maps my X here to the integer domain.
So this is what I need.
And now what are the requirements?
First, so this here should of course be subjective
so that every possible integer value can be achieved.
But this is not good enough.
Second requirement is we want that every element has the same probability.
And even more, we want, this is hard to quantify in a mathematically sound term, but basically
what we want is that there's no correlation between input and output.
For example, if I increase my input by a linear factor, like if I take text 2 times x, 3 times
x, 4 times x.
input, then there should not be a linear factor in my output.
So then these two should be independent.
So this should be uniform and independent in the result.
And now the really, really bad thing is in the general sense, this is impossible.
Okay.
This is just if you look at the theoretical problems, but in the general case, this is
not feasible to do this.
Why is it not feasible to do this?
because of the pigeonhole principle.
So if my x here has a domain that is larger
than the integer domain,
then I can always construct an input sequence.
Doesn't matter which hash function you choose,
I can always construct an input sequence
such that all my inputs will end up having
the same hash value.
It must be possible to do this
because if one domain is larger than the other,
then of course I can always construct it like this.
So we should make this as unlikely
that this happens as possible.
So this is therefore the quote of Knuth,
hashing is great for people with a lot of faith in statistics.
So we should make it show that it doesn't happen.
Okay, now, but what do we,
now what do we choose as hash function?
So what is a good hash function?
And so first let's talk about perhaps
what we say in introductory lectures.
And by the way, these are bad hash functions.
So don't, so I said to bet, let's write it here,
say bet examples.
Don't use them.
Examples, identity for example.
So we say, hey, if my key is an integer,
so why not just say, okay,
hash of x, if x is an int,
is equal to x.
because this maps my inputs to the integer domain,
every possible interval can be achieved.
So why not?
Don't do this.
Terrible, really terrible, terrible things happen
if you do this.
Don't do this.
I mean, just think about this example
that we had before when we said my function here was
slots is equal to hash of x times n,
shift right, 32.
if you use this here as function
and you use their identity as such function
and the input is for example,
which is not very unlikely.
That somebody inserts as values here,
one, two, three, four.
If you use this, then all of them
will end up in slot zero, of course.
So this is really a bad, bad, bad hash function
because we see my input values that are close by.
So one, two, three, four, they're close by.
The hash values are also close by.
And this is a highly undesirable property.
So we don't want this.
So we want that the hash values that we get
are spread out all over the space
and are distributed far, far away.
So now what should we do instead?
So this is really bad.
Identity, don't do this.
Better, but still bad.
We say, for example, my use so-called Fibonacci hashing, I say my hash value of x is equal
So this is a number that I do not know by heart, unfortunately.
But basically, yeah, and, and, yeah, so this is a number
that is, this is a pretty long number.
So this is a number that is roughly, let's say, we take a constant here, c times x, and
And this C here is roughly 2 to the power of 63 times, oh sorry, we did 64 bit hash radius.
If you do 32 bit hash radius, and of course you take 2 to the power of 31 times here,
then there is a factor here, 1.1 something.
So there is a long constant that you choose.
Okay, so you can look up this number by the way.
If you search for Fibonacci hashing here and you find this constant you choose.
You choose a pretty large constant here.
Then you get a hash value.
And this hash value is not totally terrible.
The problem is, if you look at the distribution, I mean it's better than identity, but the
problem of this Fibonacci hashing here is that the high bits of the hash values are
reasonably distributed, but the low bits are not.
So there's a lot of entropy in your high bits.
So high bits good, low bits bad.
Yeah, high bits good.
Bits, okay.
So basically, therefore, what you have to do afterwards, you have to shift this sum
also that you can only use this high bit.
But how many you shift depends, of course, here on hash table size, so I cannot write
this in a closed formula easily.
So Fibonacci hashing here, you might apply and then you shift and then you use the high
bits.
And so this is better than identity, but still not very good, because even with Fibonacci hashing,
you can construct input sequences that give you pretty bad input.
Now, so what are reasonably good? Now first let's say reasonable.
And before we come to reasonable, then of course there are the hash functions that are really good,
good but it's too expensive
you can of your cost use as a hash function here this one yeah like you say hash of x
is uh for example just use a cryptographic hash yeah so it doesn't exist
now don't don't do this i mean this gives you very good hash values
but this computing is this secure hash here,
so expensive, this dominates everything.
And also don't do this.
Okay, this is too expensive.
So basically we have seen there are some things
that are cheap, like identity is as cheap as you can do.
If you're watching, it's a bit more expensive,
but it's also not very good.
So cryptographic hashes, these are really good,
but these are too far too expensive.
So we have to find something in the middle.
Yeah, and reasonable compromises between those two are,
for example, CSE is 32.
Now, strictly speaking, here's what we say basically, hash if x is csc32x, c, so of course
you need some c value.
And strictly speaking, of course, this was meant as a checksum for error detection, it
was not meant as a hash function.
But this can be implemented, it can be run in hardware, so your CPU most likely, so this
here is supported by hardware.
So therefore this computation is super cheap.
So running a CSE 32 instructions,
of course, you have something like four cycles.
So this is super cheap and the values you get out of this are pretty good.
Unless you get good hash values out of this, it's cheap.
And therefore people do this.
Even though it was never met as a hash function,
but this works very well.
The alternative is
aqua hash for example aqua hash but what they do is they take x value and then they run as
on x as also also is a crypto primitive but they don't do the full as as you do the command
but limited to, I think they do three rounds or something like this.
Limited to three rounds.
So you run a cryptographic encryption scheme a few times on your X value.
And you do this because, again, this is also supported by hardware.
So if you have a reasonably new CPU, your CPU most likely can do AES and hardware.
And if you do a few rounds of AES, this is not very expensive.
And therefore we can do this.
and then we get also pretty good hash values out of this.
Yeah, and perhaps I can do one more here just for completeness.
I cannot write the definition because it's too much code.
So now we come to a longer code.
One good code also is for example,
more hash two for example.
This is a software solution.
This also gives you a reasonable,
Let's say this is already put it into,
also a bit expensive.
So also does here hash,
here is a lot of code.
So there's no easy answer for this.
So this is the longer sequence of code that's run.
Gives you good hash functions,
this momo hash does quite a bit of computation so this takes some code and um so therefore this will
be much slower than uh csc or the aes solution because they usually require just two three
hardware instructions so these are very cheap momo hash requires you requires more of this so this is
a bit more expensive on the other hand advantage of momo hash is this is a pure software solution
this works on every processor yeah while not every processor has csc uh support or aes support
So this is portable, but slower than the other one.
But nevertheless, you should choose one of these here.
So this is a reasonable range that you can use.
Never use identity, it's super terrible.
Fibonacci hashing you can choose, also you only use with care.
Better don't use it.
I mean, you can, we can fix it and so, but not so easy to.
You can improve this here, Fibonacci hashing, by using some more tricks,
but probably don't want to use this.
Use one of these reasonable hashes here.
good results and reasonable performance.
And by the way, I said from a theoretical perspective,
it's impossible to defend about hash collisions
because I mean, if my key domain is larger
than my integer domain,
then it's fundamentally impossible
to always be collision free.
Also there must be values that have the same hash value.
And therefore if some malicious user comes to you
and gives you all values that have the same hash value,
collide brutally in your hash table and therefore your performance will degrade and there's not a
lot we can do.
Bad things happen.
On the other hand, there are a few things we can do.
It's not like if we are totally helpless.
So there are a few things we can do.
And one thing to battle this problem is, I said both a C and AS need a seed.
It doesn't really matter what you choose.
You can use any value here.
And when you choose a different seed, you will get a different hash value.
you wish.
And of course one attractive approach here is to say, I choose my cheese at random.
So when my program starts, I run the dice, I look at the dev random or something, so
I choose a random seed.
And of course I have to keep it the same over my random program, because otherwise I don't
find anything in my HTML.
So I always must use the same seed, but the seed itself is chosen at random and therefore
an attacker cannot know the seed.
advantage that it is now very, very difficult to an attacker to choose an input that collides.
Because if the seed is known and the attacker knows how your hash function works, it can construct
inputs so that it collides. If your seed is a random value, then we cannot do this. So this
we could do. Okay, this was already quite a bit of talking about hash table. And this
we are only talking about the first half of this slide, because we are only talking about the
But nevertheless, I think it's important to talk about this because probably quite a few
of the students who attend this lecture have never implemented a hash table themselves,
at least not a real production one.
Therefore, we must talk how to do this well.
Oh, strictly speaking, I forgot even half of the tricks you can do.
Sorry, because just two minutes more, I don't want to spend too much time on it because
I want to go to external memory, but just two things.
I mean, there's another problem here that our changing hash table has, even if you do
all this.
Yeah, so then my hash table here, of course, has a chain.
And of course, if you choose a good hash function, then this chain will be short, so most likely
just one element or perhaps two elements.
So it will be short.
But nevertheless, if I access an element and the element is there, what I do is I jump
to this table element here, I look it up, I find the pointer and then I jump to this.
And this means I access two memory locations.
So first this and then that.
Two memory locations.
I'm really unlucky, even three.
So afterwards this year, if I'm really unlucky.
But if I'm lucky, only two.
But nevertheless, I do two memory accesses.
And if my hash table is really large, so it's larger than my CPU cache, this means I have
two cache misses.
One cache miss here, one cache miss here.
And cache misses are expensive.
So therefore, chaining hash tables, some people claim that they are expensive and you should
not use them.
I would say a well implemented chaining hash table is most likely faster than what you can
do as alternative.
I mean, there are alternatives that are pretty high performance, but they are not that easy
to implement in a reasonable manner.
So chaining hash tables pick a pretty sweet spot between ease of implementation and good
performance.
You can build good performing chaining hash tables reasonably easy.
The non-chaining hash tables, if you want to make some good performance is possible,
but this is not so easy.
Okay.
So, but nevertheless, what can we do to improve the performance?
Just two, two, two small tips, uh, uh, tweaks you can do.
One is, and this is of course, now we come to the nasty world of real implementation.
Now if you look at the hashtag, what is written in the hashtag here, we see that here, this
here of course is a pointer.
So now what is a pointer?
A pointer is a 64-bit element here, 64 bits, and this of course some value pointing somewhere
in the memory.
Now if you look at the real hardware that we are using, we realize quickly that this
pointer only uses 48 bits and the upper bits are all zero.
And this is by design, because your hardware cannot address more than 48 bits, so it operates
all zero.
Therefore, what you want to improve your performance of hash table, what you can do is, you can
make use of this remaining 16 bits and store something useful in there.
For example, what you can do is, you can, you have a few values stored here.
Yeah, so, and then we can take the elements that we have in my chain
and look at the hash values that we did not use.
Like if you use a power of two hash tables, this means, so this is my total hash value,
my Cosmash function always gives me, for example, 34 bit, 32 bit or 64 bit.
So this is my whole total hash value.
And so this is now the part that I used for my table.
So this is used, how much ever this is used.
And then I most likely have remaining bits that I computed anyway because my hash function
did compute it, but they didn't make use of this because my hash table is not large enough.
And so I have unused bits.
So what you can now do is, you take 4 bits from your unused bits set here, 4 bits, unused.
And then you store these bits in the, these 4 bits in these remaining 16 bits here.
Because you know, these 4 bits have 16 possible values.
And then I change this zero here to a one.
That's why I use basically as a very small bitmap.
And I set a one into my bitmap for my unused hash bits.
And a zero.
Now, if you do a lookup, you read the pointer.
And then before following the pointer, you check this upper 16 bits.
If the bit that is relevant for your hash value data searching, is this bit a set?
If not, you stop immediately.
But if not, you stop immediately.
And this means that if you have a miss,
so if your element is not in the chain,
with, I mean, not always of course,
because you could have a collision in this four bits,
of course, but if you don't have a collision
in your four bits, then if you have a miss,
you only access one memory location instead of two.
Yeah, so you get only one cache miss instead of two cache misses.
Now this improved performance quite a bit,
if you have a miss.
If you have a hit, of course,
you have to go to two of both locations.
But yeah, so this is a neat trick you can implement.
The second thing you can do, you can say, okay, don't implement a chaining hash table,
instead implement an open addressing hash table.
Then you say in my hash table, I don't store the pointer to the element, but I store the
element itself.
So then here we say, let's say hash number one, then the key number one.
So then here somewhere we have hash number two, key two.
Now my table now consists of the elements instead of pointers to the elements.
Has advantage that if I want to find something, I immediately go there and then I have it,
just memory, one memory cast and that's it.
Now this advantage is, okay, what do we do with collisions?
So if I want to enter something, but there is already somebody in there.
Okay, now there are a number of approaches to fixes.
One, the best, let's say a reasonable approach, for example, is this so called Robin Hood
hashing, Robin Hood hashing.
So this means basically, so if this is taken, I go to the next location.
So I go to the next element.
If this is free, I just put myself in there.
If this is taken, I perhaps go to the next element and so on.
So I fetch the first free element.
Now at least you do this in the first approximation.
In the second approximation, you quickly realize that if you do this, your original element
can be quite far away from your start position.
And this means if you do a lookup, then you must also look at quite a few elements and
to find it.
So therefore to make this traversal shorter, when you go to a new position, you check if
your distance from your optimal, so this would be an optimal, I want to be here.
So this is my optimal position.
And then if I go here, my distance is one, if I go to the next element, the distance
is two, then three and so on.
So you go further away and now you check if your distance from optimum is
Higher than the distance of the element that is currently in there from its optimum
And if yes, you replace the current element and move the other element away and by doing this trick you limit
the
maximum distance from the from the source and so you now no longer have to traverse an unbounded number of limits
But just a bounded number of elements and this therefore you look up is much cheaper
Open addressing with Robinhood is reasonably okay.
Downside is, first, quite a bit more difficult to implement than chaining, it's quite a bit
of code.
And second, I mean, we didn't talk about parallelism at all, but a chaining hash table you can
build in parallel reasonably easy, simply with many threads.
A Robinhood hash table is not easy at all to build in parallel with multiple threads.
So therefore, in even doubt, a well implemented chaining hash table is a good first approximation.
Okay, so as you know, I spent already nearly an hour talking about in-memory hash tables.
I wanted to talk about out-of-memory hash tables, but yeah, so this is what we want to
look at next.
But first, of course, before we can look at the out-of-memory case, we have to understand
the in-memory case.
Now in principle, we would want to do this on external memory too, so on disk.
But so the basic approach that we used,
we cannot really use for disk.
Here it is just too expensive.
Because random IO on disk is super, super expensive.
At least if you have a rotating disk.
But even if you don't have a rotating disk in SSD,
reading an arbitrary block from the SSD
is quite a bit more expensive than accessing a memory location.
And so random IO is very, very problematic.
So if you would, for example, do a chaining hash table,
this would not be good.
One one access to disk at least if you're unlucky. So then you follow the chain another access to disk
Then we follow the chain further another access to disk. So this is very very expensive
This is not not good
Even worse is this one. Yes, so we could with collisions
You could say a verse case at excess to memory locations. I can do this
Worst case this one here because this happens if your hash table grows
I mean, I said choose your hash table such that is a bit larger than the number of elements
How should you do this if you don't know how many elements you will get?
Because initially if somebody does a create table, then your hash table is empty.
So you don't know how many elements you will get.
So how do you size your hash table?
So you only observe over time how many elements you have.
Therefore, this is very, very difficult.
And the usual solution of course is rehashing, which means I fill my hash table until it's
reasonably full and then decide, oh, it's too small.
Then I build a larger hash table and copy everything from my current hash table to my
new hash table.
This is already expensive in memory, but on external memory this is prohibitive.
So it's super super expensive.
In particular if you use something like a prime number hash table, because then the
new hash table has nothing to do.
So like say you have a hash table of size 11, then say oh it was too small.
So you make it larger and change it to a hash table of size 19.
So this hashed for both prime numbers.
The location of the inputs here will have nothing to do with the location of the inputs
here.
So, totally spread out, therefore this is super, super expensive.
So therefore for external storage we need something else.
We need something that avoids this terrible rehashing performance and hopefully also does
something a bit about this chaining problem if we can.
And this is what we want to look at now.
Now, and before we look at implementations, just two notes, hash tables are not as useful
in general as with tree indexes.
Because in tree indexes we can do range queries and point queries.
With hash indexes we can usually only do point queries.
So there are hashing schemes that claim to do also support range queries like order preserving
hashing for example.
But trust me, this doesn't really work.
Okay, here the slide is more polite.
In the general case, if you don't know anything about the distribution of my input, order-preserving
hashing doesn't work.
And you can even prove this.
And also because you can prove that you can construct inputs where your order-preserving
hashing must break.
So therefore, in reality, we cannot really do a range queries.
We cannot do a point queries.
But these are some consequences, of course, namely, in practices means we can only use
hash tables for primary keys.
I mean primary keys work because every primary key is unique.
Therefore, we have a quite reasonable chance
to get collision free inputs or have few collisions,
a few collisions we might have, but not too many.
Excuse me.
If there's a primary key, that's okay.
Then I most likely have no collisions or few collisions and I can live with this
But what about a non-primary case like in index and arbitrary would a be
So then could be here's what we already talked about when we talked about indexes in general
How do I delete a tuple where one million other tuples have the same value?
Yes, so the speed trees we do the trick of
Appending the tuple ID. So my trick here was I use key comma tuple ID to make it unique because this combination is unique
So then I can find everything.
Yeah, but I cannot do this.
Yeah, because if I just want to find a key,
then this would require a range query,
and a hashed index doesn't support a range query.
So therefore I cannot do this.
Now, so therefore in reality,
hash tables can only be used for primary keys.
So for elements that are unique.
Now the last element here says,
we could fix this by having a separate index for duplicate values.
So what you could do is, you have hash table,
so then you have here elements here,
so key, key, and so on.
And initially you implement, for example,
a classical chaining or whatever.
And then if at some point you realize
that your chain becomes very long
because you have a lot of collisions,
So because every value tends to have the same value, so every entry has the same value here,
what you then do is you switch your whole chain.
So we keep the first input, but then I switch my whole chain to a tree.
So we can build, at least in principle, a hybrid of a hash table and a tree.
So we start with a hash table and if too many identical values, then I switch to a tree structure.
And then we can guarantee, of course, that we can get logarithmic excess cost even in this combination.
Yeah, but this is super complicated to implement.
I know a few implementations of this, but this is super, super difficult.
Most likely you don't want to do this.
So easy, I want to use a hash table when you know everything is unique or use a B-tree.
If not, but this hybrid of both can be built, but it's very, very difficult.
Okay, and I've seen already that I have only 12 minutes left.
All right, in 12 minutes we can do this.
So therefore now we now want to look at a hash table that works on disk and avoids these
terrible problems.
So to make it work easily, we would have to know hash table size, we cannot know it.
If you make it too small, we have too many collisions.
If you make it too large, we waste a lot of space and also performance is poor because
hashing doesn't work.
Now also chaining doesn't really work on disk
because jumping from one bucket to the other is not good.
Okay.
Now we set the traditional solution
to unknown table sizes rehashing.
So we built a new table and update everything,
but we touch everything there
and it's super, super expensive.
So therefore the idea of extendable hashing now is
we built a hash table that can be grown without rehashing.
And we do this by sharing hash table entries.
So we're just reusing what we already have.
So now how does this work?
So first my hash table size is always a power of two.
So I have size two, four, eight, 16, and so on.
So always a power of two.
And the hash table now points to a bucket and each bucket of course is a page.
And now multiple entries can point to the same bucket, but the pointing of entries to
bucket is always symmetrical, which means we have a body scheme.
I'm not sure if you are familiar with the term body scheme, the body systems, you might have
learned about this in operating systems because there's a popular strategy. Basically, a set of
values are bodies, if, so when is the number of values, bodies?
So, a BUDDYS, Z is a BUDDYS system,
sorry, I cannot write on my pen here,
is a BUDDYS system,
system if first size of s is above 2 so can be 2, 4 and so on and entries second elements
means in s are neighboring so this is a dense span basically neighboring like for example the
values can be two three four five and so but by the way this is not a body system because
two three four five oh no it was it was it nevertheless is not a body system but at least
it might currently there's no contradiction yet because it is the power of two and they are
neighboring.
But the third conditional says, last log 2 size of s, it must be identical.
Okay, so basically, so if you look at the values here, for example, 0, 1, 2, 3, so
these two are bodies, these two are bodies, these four are bodies, but 1 and 2 for example,
these are not bodies.
Because a set must be a power of 2 and the last bit must be the same and they must be
neighboring.
And so we basically takes a whole range and always break it down into halves.
And then we end up with a body set we have.
But this is the structure that we want to have.
And now the depth of buckets varies.
I don't know what depth means.
Depth means how many bits did I use for my hash function from the input.
So in this case, here we have now a small hash table.
the contextual contains only two elements and so we say basically we use one bit from my input here
because and and if my input if my input hash bit is zero i go to that bucket and if my input a bit
from a hash bit is one i also go to this bucket which means of course my depth here is zero
i use no bit now it doesn't matter what you do depth is
depth
is zero because i know no bit is required so in my bucket here and i have two values in my bucket
a and b now if you insert something in my bucket let's say i insert a bucket value c then of course
it's full yeah of course i don't have space for c my page is full so i want to insert c what i do
now is i split my bucket so i take this one bucket with a and b and transform it first first for the
the first moment ignores this, see here.
So I take my one bucket that contained A and B.
So I take A, B and I transform it into two buckets,
one containing A and one containing B.
Now, how did I do this?
I used now one bit more.
Initially I used zero bits from hash value
because it doesn't matter what you do.
Now I decided to use one bit.
So I took this bucket, I took all elements from a bucket,
A and B, I look at the hash value and I saw, okay,
If I look again one bit here, if you look at the last bit of my hash value, then I see
if I take an a, I get a zero, if I take a b, I get a one.
Therefore they end up in two different buckets and I have two buckets.
And now I can, I have free space and now I can insert my c, so I have depths here.
Okay.
So in this case, I could just do this because I could unshare a pointer.
So initially here's this point that was shared, both pointers were pointing to the same bucket.
I could unshare this and therefore increase my depth in, if this is not possible.
And so then I must increase the global depths and then must increase the total dictionary.
Okay.
I see this in a moment, but before we do this, let's make a slightly larger example.
So let's assume my input here was at a bare hashtag of size with two bits.
Initially again I used zero bits, so everything points here to A, B. So now I want to insert
a C, then I said oh, so this is of course bad.
So then we split this in, now we, instead of one bucket now we have two buckets.
We had A and B.
Now in my example here, we did say that, let's say this point here and this point here and
now I could insert a C.
Now if I want to insert a D again, for example, it ends up to happen in this bucket here.
Bucket is full.
what now happens is I split this bucket again.
And then I can, for example, end up with C, B, and then could be that my D ends up here,
and then everything's fine. And then nothing happens with A.
Now, so you see if a bucket overflows, I split this single bucket.
And of course I update the pointers to that bucket, but all other buckets that I have in
So this is a local change.
So this is of course good because I don't have to rewrite my, my hash table.
I just have to have to update a few pointers in my single bucket.
And this is ideally what I want.
Okay.
And now if this is not possible, so in this example here, if it has this, this table,
forget this example, if it is stable here, my ABC and now I want to insert something
and BC is full, I cannot, I cannot get unshare because there is no sharing.
In that case, I double my table.
I go to four entries.
And now, because I used one bit more,
I now say that, okay,
originally I just used to,
this was my original one,
the first one original, this is new.
So original bit was zero and then the new bit.
So we say original bit zero,
it doesn't matter if the new bit is one or zero,
everything points to A.
Then if the original bit is one and the new bit is zero,
I go to B, otherwise if it's one, I go to C and D.
Okay.
And this means we have split one,
But the bucket with a was unaffected.
We didn't do anything with the bucket.
And the new bucket is then linked in as usual.
Okay.
And so it's more invasive because I've had to rewrite the dictionary, but I did not have
to rewrite the buckets.
And of course the buckets are much larger than the dictionary, because if you just think
about this, we have here, this is a database page.
So this is a page and on a page with a dictionary, we can probably point to a thousand entries
or so.
So the table will probably be smaller than by data, by a factor of a thousand.
Smaller than the data.
Those are buckets.
It depends on your size or so, but this point.
So therefore, if you rewrite my table, this is far less bad than having to rewrite all
the buckets.
This is expensive, but it's not super expensive.
Okay.
And then I can just increase the number of bits.
Now, the only problem is, I cannot grow the table with an unbounded size, because if all
of this double double double, you all know about exponential functions.
So at some point you cannot do this anymore.
So your exponential growth must stop at some point.
And so therefore, at some point you probably have to fall back to chaining, even in extensible
hashing.
So we don't want this.
never happens because if your hash functions are good then this simply never happens it's
you reach your maximum hash table size but you know remember hash function could be bad or you
have some malicious user that gives you a lot of values with the same hash value and then of course
you have a problem because if you have really real conditions collisions on your values or at
least in the bits that you use so then increasing their stable size doesn't help you much but for
the real collision doesn't help you at all because i mean if they're identical then after increasing
So therefore we need some strategy to handle this.
Yeah, but nevertheless, we hope that this never happens.
And then we can cope with this and we can process this.
Okay, now the advantages of extended rehashing are ideally,
we need exactly two page accesses per lookup.
Because we look at the dictionary once
and then we look at the bucket and that's it.
And this which is less than a B-tree.
Because in a B-tree we expect to have something like two or three elements,
excesses, perhaps even four, if the input is really large.
So therefore, extended behashing is expected to be faster than a B-tree.
And also a good thing here is we can grow the table independent of the existing bucket
and we don't have to do rehashing.
Okay, so these are all advantages.
Now disadvantages, table growth is a very invasive operation.
we have to copy the table and the table can be large.
Smaller than the data, but nevertheless it's large.
And this also leads to very large steps in space consumption.
Because initially my table is small, of course, you have a small table.
Then time passes and double the size.
Okay, still okay.
And then double the size, still okay.
And then double the size, then still okay.
Then, you know, out of screen.
And so we have, we have extreme steep steps in space consumption.
every time when the bucket, when the table doubles here.
Okay.
And then the next problem here is
what do we do with hash collisions?
Because if we have real hash collisions,
then we have serious problems.
And yeah, so of course we hope this doesn't happen,
but nevertheless, we need to do something
in the case that this happens.
And this all makes extensible hashing quite complicated.
Okay, but I'm out of time now.
So therefore I will stop here.
And we will now, we will look at other techniques
bring hash tables to disk in the next lecture.
Okay, thank you.